der kampf gegen das bienensterben geht
los besser gesagt der kampf gegen die
keller milbe aber wie jetzt bei klicks
und science fiction
erst kürzlich haben wir von einer studie
der wissenschaftler der homepage der
hochschule für gesundheitswesen
berichtet diese haben eine studie in der
fachzeitschrift science veröffentlicht
was passiert wenn alle bienen aussterben
der studie nach gehen dann 23 prozent
früchte 16 prozent gemüse 22 prozent
müsse um 22 prozent getreide verloren
die prozentzahlen beziehen sich alle auf
den weltweiten bestand neben dem das
mehrere milliarden menschen an vitamin a
oder an so lange leiden würden gäbe es
jährlich 142 millionen mehr tote würden
nur 50 prozent der bienen aussterben gab
es immer noch 700 tausend tote im jahr
experten in hohen neuendorf kämpfen auf
hochtouren
gegen das bienensterben doch wie
in hohen neuendorf leben derzeit ca 350
bienenvölker das sind gute 15 millionen
bienen die bienen würden jährlich mehr
als 20.000 leser ab 500 gramm füllen mit
diesen fleißigen bienen versucht man
jetzt eine bienen zu züchten die den
aktuellen umständen widerstehen kann
unter den aktuellen umständen versteht
man beispielsweise die varroa-milbe um
diese dreht sich die forschungen hohen
neuendorf die varroa-milbe kommt
eigentlich also ursprünglich aus dem
asiatischen tierreich die biene dort die
aps c rahner lässt sich von der varroa
destructor jedoch nicht beeindrucken
lässt ruhe ist lateinisch und bedeutet
soviel wie zerstören
da muss man glaube ich zu der
namensgebung nicht unbedingt sagen die
aber ist sehr aner hat jedoch gelernt
mit der killer milbe umzugehen
hierzulande lebende apis mellifera
mellifera feld der über jedoch noch
immer zum opfer
das soll sich in zukunft ändern zu viele
bienen sind schon gestorben
vor 25 jahren lebten dem deutschen
imkerbund zufolge circa 12 millionen
bienenvölker in deutschland 2005 waren
es nur noch knapp 700.000 neben den
pestiziden ist die killer milbe einer
der hauptgründe des rückgangs die milbe
zu bekämpfen was nicht gerade leicht sie
schleicht sich nämlich schon sozusagen
ins kinderbett der bienen in diesem jahr
berichtet sie dann gewaltigen schaden an
sie sorgt dafür dass die jungen bienen
mit einem nicht wirklich
funktionstüchtigen immunsystem
aufwachsen
was das dann bedeutet es ja wohl klar
die forscher in hohen neuendorf haben
der milbe schon vor zehn jahren den
krieg erklärt
viele von euch können sich
wahrscheinlich gar nicht vorstellen wie
man dann gegen das bienensterben
vorgehen soll kann oder soll ist ja auch
nicht verwunderlich viel wissen über
diese kleinen tiere haben wir laien ja
oft nicht den hohen neuendorf läuft der
kampf gegen die killer milbe
folgendermaßen teile einer bienenwabe
werden mit varroamilben verseucht ein
infrarot kamera beobachtet dann die dort
lebenden bienen wenn eine biene diese
mögen aufspürt und gegebenenfalls sogar
bekämpft wird sie markiert und
herausgenommen mit den schlauen bienen
wird dann ein neues bienenvolk gezüchtet
so versucht man immer mehr resistente
bienen zu gewinnen es gibt allerdings
noch eine etwas einfachere methode an
deren hohen neuendorf gearbeitet wird an
einer sogenannten dna methode bzw an
einem dna chip
die dna chips sollen die arbeit viel
leichter machen mit hilfe der chip soll
es möglich sein
genauer erbinformationen der bienen zu
erhalten so kann man dann direkt
erkennen welche gene dafür sorgen dass
die ein bienen aufgrund der des
milbenbefall sterben und die anderen
überlegen wenn es einen solchen chip
gibt wird er aber wohl erstmal für die
meisten imker unbezahlbar sein
der kampf gegen das bienensterben wird
bis dahin vermutlich nur von experten
weiter geführt werden
zitat würde man nicht gegen varroa
vorgehen gäbe es in deutschland
vielleicht sogar in europa bald keine
bienen mehr so der koordinator des smart
des projekts in hohen neuendorf kaspar
bienefeld wie sehr uns menschen das
bienensterben gefährdet erfahrt ihr im
video hier nein hier oben
das bedroht die menschheit so ab und zum
block kommt hier unten und diskutiert
doch mal unten in den kommentaren wie
ein beitrag gegen das bienensterben von
uns also von uns laien aussehen könnte
ich bin sehr gespannt und bis dann
wünsch euch noch eine schöne woche